Speaker 1: Let's go next to Jake from
Chicago, Jake from Chicago. You're on the air.
Jake from Chicago, you were on the air.
Speaker 2: Hello, can you hear me, David?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 3: Hey, David,
I'm a longtime listener. Thank you. Currently
a student at the University of Alabama. And
one recent trend among these Southern College
football games has been the Joe Biden chance.
Hearing these lunatics completely make ironic,
keep politics out of sports and then feel the
need to disrupt the environment of the game. How
do we approach dealing with these kinds of people?
Speaker 1: Will approach in what sense?
You mean what should be done at the game
when the chant breaks out? Or more generally,
Speaker 3: this is the general speaking like,
how can we just like change it so
that these people aren't completely
hypocritical? Went with what they say.
Speaker 1: I'm not aware of any way to
the hypocrisy has actually. We've been covering
the hypocrisy for more than a decade on the show
and the hypocrisy has only gotten worse and worse.
My body, my choice when it comes to the vaccine,
but not when it comes to abortion. No debt and
deficit are bad except when it's a Republican
president. Don't regulate businesses except
when they want to require vaccinations. So
I think it's a lost cause on the hypocrisy.
I think we've just got to figure out a way
to not be annoyed with them. And I've been reading
about the chants at the football games like, wow,
big surprise, a football audience in the
south of the United States doesn't look
like Joe Biden. It's got to me, it's kind
of like it's not really big news, you know?
Speaker 3: Yeah. I remember when two years ago
when Trump came to the Alabama versus LSU game,
I've never heard a louder stadium
in my life. It was just crazy. These
people going absolutely nuts for this man.
Speaker 1: Yeah, well, that is the South and
they tend to vote Republican. So not really
surprising. But, you know, quite frankly,
I'd be avoiding large sporting events at this
point in time. And then I'm both skipping the
covid risk as well as the by anti Biden chance.
Speaker 3: Yeah, that's fair. I, I enjoy going
to the games, but I'm also messed up at the game,
so I'm trying everything I can to mitigate. But I
completely understand about nine.
Speaker 1: Oh that's interesting. How how many
other are people tending to wear masks. It's not.
Speaker 3: No nobody nobody has masks on there.
Our school does have a mask
mandate. Yeah. But in outdoor
areas people don't really follow it as much.
Speaker 1: Oh right. OK, yeah. And outdoor it
is less, less, less important. I would agree.
All right. Well, stay safe down there, Jake.
Speaker 2: Well, thank you.
Thank you for having me on.
Speaker 1: There is, Jake. Let's take a
quick break. If you're holding to talk to me,
don't hang up because we're going
right back to the phones momentarily